the Joe Rogan experience John Hoffman
who is Chuck Liddell's former trainer
trainer of actually current trainer if
he still works out trainer clover to
share just one of the best guys in MMA
he has these little videos on his
Instagram I think it's the pit or pit
master pit master on Instagram talking
about Street self-defense things and
he's always advocating hitting people
with your palm so people break their
hands on top it's not the whole thing
hit him in the nose to kind of that's
not real that's not real the idea of
drive the bone up you'll break their
nose not that you're gonna kill them but
like that's the easiest self-defense
maybe where even the side of the head
but the idea is hitting him with the
palm I thought you're gonna say when I
said that's not real there was one where
kids it was like a karate movie yes a
guy would hit the palm up to the nose
the nose bone would go into the brain it
would kill someone that happened there
like a Seagal movie I just smash him in
the nose I thought you're gonna say that
but the idea is he you could just
without worry of consequences you could
palm strike someone in the face like
really hard and never break your hand a
regular person throwing a punch you have
a real good chance of breaking your hand
okay real good chance like if you crack
someone in the forehead most likely
you're gonna break your hand let that
rest or something else but with your
palms you can just [ __ ] way lay
somebody you could smack the [ __ ] out of
somebody but then you look kind of silly
there was a an organization that MMA
more organization back in the early days
called pancrase I think they might be
still around but they have modified
rules but a Pancrase back in the day
they were wrestling shoes with shin pads
and they were like little tiny little
speedos and they would smack each other
with their hands
so they'd kick and punch and do
submission techniques was fairly crude
in comparison to today's MMA but we got
to see a lot of leg locks back then and
there was there was some fishy fights
too but my point is like bas Rutten was
the first guy I figured out how to
really [ __ ] people up with palm strikes
and what he did is he has really
flexible wrists he's a badass striker so
he learned how to pull his hands way
back and he would just throw them like
punches he would just do the same
motions that he would do with a punch
but just smash guys with his with his
palms and he was lighting people up like
Christmas tree
that is horrific to what he [ __ ] he
Kayode a bunch of people with his palms
huh CB watch bas Rutten KO put bas
Rutten Kayo's Funaki he kod Funaki who
is like an elite MMA fighter who was a
Hicks and Gracie's last opponent when
Hickson was fighting MMA but Funaki I
think started out in Pancrase and bas
Rutten K Odom and the way K Odom was
like like like a punch but he was doing
it with his palms huh just smashing
people it's just like your hand like
there's a lot of things you think
wouldn't work clotheslines one of them
that [ __ ] would work okay that's my
point
but mind not the honky tonk man's move
though what's long to talk to shake
rattle and roll and just flips him on
his back it's like why is this even hurt
mmm you don't remember this you don't
watch wrestling in the 80s
no well how about the DDT here so here's
boss oh you that knee oh yeah back up
before that back up before that here
watch him he's so he's usually box was a
[ __ ] gorilla back then another size
him see smacking his [ __ ] out of them
he's using his hand see how he's hitting
him with yes he's throwing him like
punches but this knees one did it boom
yeah boss was a beast man he was a
[ __ ] beast he was probably the first
really elite striker that we saw an MMA
were you like whoa like this is what can
happen like when he was kicking people
and pancrase everybody was like whoa
like this is this guy can [ __ ] kick
like you've seen a lot of guys who were
kicking that were kind of like karate be
yeah maybe they didn't have as much
power but bas was he was a Dutch kick
box he was smashing people boom he looks
scary [ __ ] - he was a bad [ __ ]
the head [ __ ] he won the UFC
heavyweight title he was the first guy
ever I think in my recollection to win a
title off of his back by from strikes he
fought Kevin Randleman Kevin ranima is a
badass for us so he kept taking them
down and boss was beating the [ __ ] out
of him from the bottom throwing elbows
and butt and they gave him a decision
which a lot of people disagreed with
throws like man you look at the volume
of strikes landed but damage it
anymore you just just being on top so I
couldn't enough you have to actually do
something with the position